hey everybody Welcome to visual effects
artists react we have some Great Clips
today in fact we have a sweet clip that
is a small soldiers reboot
is it Unreal Engine no way I know I love
it I love revealing that also I've been
dying to get Star Trek on this series
for a long time and I think I have the
perfect clip to kick it off
's gonna be looking at the Human Torch
from the original Fantastic Four move
5 starring Chris Evans I don't think the
CGA I aged very well they definitely
have a challenge of trying to have like
a human that can emote inside this fire
and finally I'm going to test some CGI
to see if it makes Ren feel something
because I'm going to show Ren his
greatest fear
[Music]
Commandos
you guys remember that movie Small
Soldiers yeah I I was like I forgot
about Small Soldiers I was like yeah
I've been wanting to cover that on the
show it's gritty Toy Story did you see
this like cool reboot proof of concept
that came out no wait what it's it's
really cool here just just start playing
it just play just look at this it's
sweet War for the necron
this is all blender wait is this a
render bro this is freaking Unreal
Engine Unreal Engine no way I know I
love it I love revealing that
like the plastic Shader is perfect yeah
it looks so good this is Unreal Engine
no way oh look I hate to be the unreal
guy which I obviously am but
unreal has path racing in it guys I mean
okay you can do a real render like a
real render using Unreal now but then
the name they said you can't but then
unreal it's unreal but that's the whole
thing with all these new updates that
came out they got you know the nanite
stuff the Lumen stuff that's cool but
now in like 5.2 they found a way to
unifile most of the rendering systems to
work with path tracing so just to
clarify path tracing is basically how
modern renders work where they simulate
the light bouncing around the room the
way it takes on color bounces off
surfaces Etc illuminates the space you
look at old rendering it's a single
light harsh Shadows no soft Shadows
anywhere no bounce light to modern day
rendering you have all this bounce light
this globe illumination different kind
of service materials or fraction
Reflections all this great stuff but
video games don't really have any of
that because they're trying to do all
this real-time stuff and unreal engines
like whatever we'll just also add that
to our incredible engine here so the
path tracing in Unreal Engine is not
real time no
how unreal time is it
no no it's like anything else like what
like what are you 20 seconds per frame a
minute per frame like whatever you want
it's just like anything else so this
probably still took a while to render oh
this looks incredible this took a long
ass time to render I have more technical
questions but we're still like look at
this reacting here
[Music]
I like that touch whenever she's firing
at this alien that little BB hits the
door and leaves a little impression a
little circular impression there like it
actually would if you're to shoot
something with the pig yeah you see that
yeah man this looks really nice it's
animated really well I know the
animation is incredible the reveal to
this Army of monster toys yeah like his
wings spread out and then the wings turn
into a little something little
characters yeah how would you describe
this animation it looks toy like it
looks physical it looks like when you
wiggle your action figures you take an
action figure and shake it it's like you
know they even got little hairs on them
yeah did you see the little hair on that
it's like a little fuzz that's like one
of those little details you add to a
render to actually like kind of ground
it in reality like all the dust
particles on the actual surface the
plastic is an intentional addition man
these box physics like when the Box
flaps waiver and stuff it's like such a
small touch that's really impressive so
I think it's important to note that
although this is Unreal Engine a lot of
that stuff was probably made outside of
unreal oh yeah
classic shroud of the packaging getting
ripped open and whatnot it is deceptive
you're right because like a lot of these
animations are created outside of the
program yeah I mean some of that can
definitely be done in unreal just fine
but it's definitely a blend this is
clearly created by a team of really
talented artists yeah it's cool it's a
sweet little sweet little piece cool
toys that's super cool we'll do a real
small soldiers movie look in another
episode it's like one of those films
like deserves research
is that the new Small Soldiers trailer
man there's toys are jacked
come here come here okay like not
everyone can be injection molded into
the perfect body like those toys but you
know humans actually have to work for it
which brings me to today's sponsor
co-pilot which is the perfect tool to
get you to your fitness goals come on
okay so I'm like really into fitness and
I take it super seriously I personally
love co-pilot because there is a real
life person on the other end of my cell
phone that I can constantly talk to so
when I was using an in-person personal
trainer I had to set my workout schedule
to the times that worked for them but
now with this co-pilot app I can work
out at 2AM if I wanted to they're still
going to see that I worked out they'll
still be able to see everything that I
did and what I accomplished at the end
of every workout when you submit it you
can see where your heart rate was up or
down what reps you did the best if you
hit a new streak you can see what body
muscles you have targeted during that
workout co-pilot has personalized
workout programs made by experts and
over 75 percent of co-pilot clients
continue to work out after a hundred
days which means copilot clients are
nine times more successful at sticking
to their goals okay look you have
nothing to lose and everything to gain
click that co-pilot link below or use
the QR code on the screen to get 14 days
free with your own Expert Fitness health
coach okay I won't take up any more of
your time let's get back to react I
wonder what they're going to look at
next
set a course for Earth maximum war I've
been trying to figure out a way to start
the conversation about Star Trek on this
show I know so I think I may have found
the clip that is the best conversation
starter for Star Trek like when I think
about Star Trek and I think about like
most memorable moments it's it's up
there like top five for me is this the
shot I think it is it might be it's the
one from first Contact let's just watch
it the Borg have a collective
consciousness
there are no individuals when I saw this
I saw this in the theater with my mom it
is the shot oh man I am the beginning
It's gotta be a puppet do you know this
shot no maybe it's not a puppet oh man
this is incredible right here
oh wow
hold on
[Music]
right
well done Star Trek
yeah it might honestly be all downhill
from here as far as like cool VFX shots
because I think this might be the
coolest one in all of Star Trek history
yeah uh but here's the thing it not only
is it a cool shot from a concept
standpoint but for the time as well it's
insanely impressive do you know who did
the shot you know the guys it's like one
of the four main famous guys
so does xylem okay yeah yeah John Noel
obviously I told you he's one of the
guys
[Laughter]
so do you guys remember when we were
looking at the shots of the hand from
Adam's Family yes but you know how you
do that you have a hand with a
prosthetic stump and then it's a green
or blue arm yeah so it's kind of what's
Happening Here for the head and torso
that's her real head and that's a
prosthetic torso and her body is
actually in a blue morph suit that's
kind of hanging off prone she's being
lowered down by a mechanically
controlled motion control arm the camera
is motion control as well which
basically allows this prosthetic torso
to effectively line up to exactly where
she's going to be standing so she's
standing there in the end of the shot in
the same pose that she's being lowered
down into and then they're using a
little bit of a morph after her like
torso gets sealed in to transition to
the next performance so there's two
shots happening here so the shot of her
head there lowering down and then in a
moment from here when she's now walking
away those are two separate shots
there's definitely one morph happening
you can tell on the bottom of the Torso
yeah you have the liquify effect on our
car going over her shoulders and then a
morph happening as it pulls her skin
down the animation of the suit like
clasping to her skin is solid like it's
really well done it's cool this is super
cool I love this it is really cool I
think you're right Sam this is probably
the most iconic Star Trek shot this is
also Star Trek effects in a nutshell a
very slow two characters talking to each
other singular thing and it's like ta-da
Peter you know I love Star Trek So Fine
Art you know Art's good because it makes
you feel something you don't have to be
like a trained art historian right you
know a movie is good it just makes you
feel something you don't have to be a
movie critic so how do you know if CGI
is good how do you know if effects are
good the way it makes you feel it's just
the way you make it makes you feel so in
this next clip let's just watch Ren
let's see how it makes you feel and
we'll be able to tell the CGI is good or
not wait so I watch Ren or this the clip
but we can watch the clip okay but you
guys you guys get to walk around
check out Brad
oh no
no we gotta get out of here they're
coming looks like the only thing going
is you do
oh oh oh holy
yeah I guess the CG hasn't aged as well
because Ren's just like whatever you
know we still haven't talked about what
if the CGI makes you feel nothing
they are using the same animation over
and over again they're all just like
jumping
but that does challenge there's also
some shots that have aged well I think
just the rendering of the spider you can
tell that they're CG spiders and I'm not
exactly sure why right now it's
animation all the way there's some janky
animation some nice animation I mean
it's a hard thing it's like when you
have to animate I don't know 100 spiders
some of them are going to get some
really nice attention and some of them
aren't going to get as much attention
like this part coming up I think has a
very nice animation
[Music]
uh yeah no this looks like the one the
way the one slides like bumps the other
one that shot is good yeah the shape of
this spider doesn't trigger my fear
response at all
[Applause]
like big body short legs they don't do
it for me shiny legs that are long that
that freaks me out
yikes there it is there we go that's the
feeling those ones no thank you
the striped legs yep and they're shiny
this scene right here is it's really
satisfying like this is this is a nice
scene coming up it's a nice wholesome
scene
this part's for you
foreign
[Laughter]
they're full of lime juice they're
highly pressurized spiders Ren is just
starting to squirm here and if you want
to actually see us continue to make him
squirm head over to Corridor digital.com
for the extended version of this reactor
from his core
trick question so Fantastic Four
starring Captain America himself as the
Human Torch I kind of found the effects
to be rather impressive so I kind of
wanted to get you guys thoughts on it I
got an idea
don't even think about it never do what
are you doing torch out what do you say
flame on Torch out
dude it's windy so he needs to cup their
hands around him why is oh it's because
he's really hot so that's why the
missile's going after him he's hot even
before he's fiery yeah I don't think the
cgai aged very well what he felt about
the spiders first time you saw him is
how I feel about this fire they
definitely have a challenge of trying to
have like a human that can emote inside
this fire Ren why did you pick this clip
because there's a lot going on behind
the scenes here a lot of these shots
were fully CG some of the shots were
like day for night shots like where they
actually filmed in the middle of the day
in the city for like the cars and
whatnot and used the intense day time as
part of the illumination pass but also
you know this came out in 2005 so
working on this 2004 2005-ish there
weren't really like fire simulation
tools back then and the tools that did
exist were very very rudimentary and it
is a bunch of different passes of a
bunch of different scales of actually
simulated fire all comped onto actual
footage of Chris Evans here wait it's
actual Chris Evans yeah so they filmed
one pass of him just like laying down on
like a surfboard type thing and then
they would match move a 3D model of him
and you use that to basically generate a
bunch of the the fire that's being
simulated around him that was good
actually yeah this looks pretty good you
can see some of the stepping in the
simulation where it's like kind of
skipping voxels a little bit you kind of
see like the the horizontal lines but
they were able to get rid of that using
motion blur so they would do an actual
pass for the vectors of it and then
combine those together to actually get
like the nice like smeary fire motion
blur goes a long way you can kind of see
the different passes that are being
added on top of him because you can't
really simulate all this stuff at the
same time you have to do it in pieces
and just combine it man the color was so
good in the test but like the hyper
orange saturation it's like that's a
struggle with CG fire especially back
then when like the full dynamic range
isn't fully worked out well it's because
you lose that contrast it looks really
good against the black background you
can really see the detail of the
simulation but then when you just put
the same color behind the fire it makes
it harder to see that detail and then
the final compositing pass kind of blows
out the exposure on a lot of it so you
additionally lose more of that I'm
really curious to see what the Human
Torch looks like in the ill-fated
Fantastic Four movie that came out in
like 2009 2010 2015.
oh look he's dark he's dark they made
him dark they yeah they basically just
gave him super white eyes and a white
mouth so it stands out from that dark
background I think this looks a lot
better with a darker core yeah it
totally does I think they had that
realization of like we gotta see the
Flames better but now you said the
problem of like okay so I want you guys
to CGI in a really bright light it's
like okay what should we do for the
background photography just set the
camera and get a dolly shot it's like oh
that should be so much brighter in that
room yeah so much brighter yeah the
simulation looks better in the yeah for
sure Fantastic Four but it's always
weird to me like how these things just
don't get done on Films where it's like
everybody knows how bright fire is like
you can go and you can make a campfire
but like they still under lit the room
it's like there's a whole bonfire in
front of this dude and there's no light
reflecting off of his head yeah you're
right yeah they keep digging that
highlight there and just tinted that a
difference it's like sir what's this
plate gonna be used for it's like is
this where he's working with the Human
Torch okay let's light it with the blue
it's like this isn't the Human Torch
supposed to be there it's like yeah is
he gonna be like hot is that like nah
this is one of the cold scenes it's
funny though each film has like their
own strength where like the comping of
the earlier Fantastic Four movies is
really really good yeah and I feel like
it handles the brightness of the fire
like you see how much care they put into
lighting the scenes and doing all the
lens work to make it feel like it's
there whereas this the design of the
character actually looks a little less
Goofy and the simulation looks great and
the simulation looks great you get the
character the shape and the form except
then they're not like placing it and
comping it properly or just like filming
the scene with enough Direction here
like yeah it just doesn't feel like it
has that extra Edge I think it's like
that's the thing it's like how do you do
it justice isn't like fire like one of
the most critique things yeah maybe on
this show it's like all right well now
here's a character that is fire oh did
you know that five of us here at
Corridor on the co-pilot program so just
a reminder click that link in the
description below or scan that QR code
to get 14 free days with your own
personal trainer thanks again for
co-pilot for sponsoring this video this
was an amazingly fun episode despite the
clip that you wanted to show me I didn't
I couldn't look at some of that
mostly but yeah thank you
thank you you've got coming